As developers strive
to remove memory leaks
from their
application, they tend
to focus the majority
of their energy
on the most impactful issues.
However, one of the biggest,
most frightening leaks
are often hanging around
in their code base
going unnoticed.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and one of the worst things
that can get leaked in
your Android application
is a view object.
For the most part, views
are simple little gizmos
that help us update the screen
and display information.
We generally don't think of
them as potential memory hogs.
Which, I mean, is kind of true.
By themselves, views aren't
much of a leak problem.
Rather, it's what they reference
that can cause
a horrible leak situation.
Remember that the garbage
collector system in Android
can only reclaim objects
there are no longer referenced
by anything else
inside of memory.
A leak is an object that
is no longer needed,
but there's still a reference
to it somewhere in the system.
This problem can
cascade when that object
references other
objects, and those objects
reference other objects.
None of them in the entire
chain can be removed from memory
because of the existing
references from that root leak.
So here's the problem.
Views contain a reference
back to the activity
that created them.
And activities, in
turn, tend to reference
lots of internal objects
and other memory items.
This is why a leaked view
object is such a big issue.
When a view leaks, so
does the activity it
references and all of
the other data involved.
Basically, the entire
activity sits around
in memory, which can
be an extreme problem
in certain situations.
For example, when the
user rotates their device,
a configuration change
will be triggered,
causing the current
activity to be destroyed
and a new instance of it
to be loaded into memory.
But if a view from that
first activity was leaked,
then the original activity
can't be cleaned up now.
And so it'll just
basically sit around
hogging memory that should
be given to the new activity instead.
Now, imagine if this happens and
the user rotates their screen back again.
Suddenly, you've now got
three separate instances
of an activity in memory
all fighting for space.
So avoiding leaking
view objects should
be the top priority for your
memory management policy.
To that end, here are
some simple patterns
that you should watch out for.
Number one, don't
reference views inside
of async callbacks.
That async event may execute
at some point in the future
where things aren't ideal.
I mean, in one situation
the activity may
have been killed before
the callback is triggered.
But the view in the
activity, as such,
will be kept around until
the async function completes
and releases its
reference to the view.
And in a worse
situation, your callback
may be executed after the
view object has actually
legitimately been destroyed,
thus dereferencing an invalid
object and causing your
application to crash.
Really not that important
for performance,
but you know the whole
crashy crashy thing
tends to shine bad on users.
Anyhow, number two,
don't reference views
from static objects.
The issue here is
that static objects
persist for the lifetime of
the entire process that's
running your app,
which by the way,
is not the same as the
lifetime of the activity that
declares the static object.
As such, having a static
object referenced to a view
can cause issues when the
activity is destroyed,
say, during a
configuration change,
because the view
is still referenced
by the static object.
And the static object
then, of course, references
the activity, as well.
Neither the view or
activity will ever
get cleaned up because of
the lifetime of that object.
And number three,
avoid putting views
in collections that don't
have clear memory patterns.
For example, using
a weak hashmap object
to store views as values.
Since weak hashmaps store
views as hard references,
you can end up in
a bad spot anytime
something destroys those views.
This type of weak
hashmap behavior
has led it to be nicknamed
the leak hashmap.
Leak, because it's
the weak hash--
Now, if you're ever wondering
where your memory is going,
make sure to check out the
Allocation Tracker tool
inside of Android Studio.
If you see content
from an activity that's
not supposed to
exist, you might need
to take a hard
look at your code.
And taking hard
looks at your code
is what Android
Performance is all about.
Which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos, and
check out the Google+ community
for other great tips.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.